ei kicked-off III earlier than ever this
year by having their press conference at
midday on Saturday they did and whether
you miss the show or you just want to
recap of the highlights stick with us
over the next few minutes and we'll get
you sorted we're going to be recapping
all the big press conferences so make
sure you're subscribed so you don't miss
a thing let's start with the big
surprises ei revealed not one but two
new IPs the first is a story driven
co-op game from Hays Light the
developers of brothers are tailored to
sons a bloody excellent game by the way
called a way out the game looks to be
set in the 1970s and follows a pair of
criminals as they progress from prison
escape to get away chase to another
caper interestingly the game is only
playable in split-screen local or online
co-op with each player's experience
independent of the others an example of
which was one player enjoying a cutscene
while the other player was able to move
around the environment a way out is
later to arrive in early 2018 for Xbox
one ps4 and PC oh man I want to play
this one so bad
I loved brothers I loved great stories I
loved new IP and I loved the look of
this game the second new IP was a sci-fi
futuristic game from Bioware called
anthem we only received a tiny little
teaser video ahead of a proper reveal at
Microsoft's show tomorrow but what we
did see was suits of armor giant
monsters and plenty of foreboding
narration about a wall that keeps people
safe from the evil beyond look it's not
Knight to the Old Republic but I'm still
optimistic as for a game you're probably
already well acquainted with EA revealed
a summer of battlefield event which will
conclude with the arrival of the Russian
themed multiplayer focused expansion in
the name of the Czar this September the
new expansion will include new weapons a
new behemoth vehicle female soldiers and
new areas not seen in battlefield 1 if
that feels like a little too long of a
wait for you a total of 8 new maps will
Daboo over the next few months including
six that are tied to the expansion
battlefield premium members will get
access to the new locations early the
first of which are French themed
nighttime Maps pries d'etat and naval
nights which are both arriving in July
they also brought it home in the sports
department this year with a number of
interesting announcements a new trailer
for Madden NFL 18 showed off a story
mode called longshot which follows an
aspiring football player trying to make
it into the NFL the mode also includes a
character voice by moonlight
on the Hershel alley which is pretty
damn cool and yes this all does sound
curiously similar to the story mode in
fifa called the journey which is making
a return in FIFA 18 ea also revealed
that the game will arrive on September
26 in the US for ps4 Xbox one and PC
it'll arrive worldwide on September 29
if basketball is more your game ea
revealed NBA Live 18 is on the way and
it's going to put emphasis on
personalization
I also hope you're not sick of story
mode because NBA Live 18 will feature a
somewhat RPG s mode called the one where
you play as your own custom character
live 18 also brings back a 5v5 Street
ball mode where you can team up with
friends to take on others on real-life
courts the game is out this September
need for speed payback also finally made
an appearance with a meaty fast and
furious esque gameplay trailer where the
play is shown catching up to a speeding
truck and taking down house in forces by
smashing into them
it features plenty of thrills and fast
cars a previously confirmed that you'll
control three different characters and
it appears you'll switch between them
pretty seamlessly payback is out on
November 10 for ps4 Xbox one and PC Star
Wars Battlefront 2 was also shown off by
way of a new cinematic trailer and a
live 20 V 20 gameplay demo and the most
exciting part all Maps heroes and DLC
will be completely free and they're
promising three times the content of the
first game including More Heroes maps
vehicles and weapons a new feature that
is being introduced is a class system
which will affect things like abilities
and health loadouts there will also be
themed seasons of content drops from
dice the first of which will revolve
around the next main line Star Wars film
the last Jedi and introduced Finn and
Captain phasma as playable heroes as was
a map on the planet crate as seen in the
film's teaser and to prove that they're
committed to showing you all areas of
Star Wars an impressive multiplayer
battle on feed the capital of Naboo was
shown off and you may remember that from
the best prequel film The Phantom Menace
and guess what you can finally fight as
battle droids that's all the best stuff
we saw at the EA press conference but do
remember that III is just getting kicked
off we're gonna have a roundup for every
single press conference so be sure you
hit that subscribe button grab our game
spot now app from iOS and Android and
we'll see you guys tomorrow after
beautiful Microsoft by